foreign  [Music]  [Music]  you're gonna be here all night  ready Sue  we've got a spectacular show with some  amazing talents  dad take the kids home then watch out  for Timmy he's a biter I'm not changing  any diapers  the producer said the ratings were  dropping of course they were look at you  guys now ew  I'm the joke always of town  oh Manny you complete me  hey Deary call Judy oh I cannot get the  password no no hold on face scan oh nice  smile life was hard for small mammals  [Music]  welcome to zootopia's biggest talent  competition  drop that beat  so I'll just move this table over here  might get a little musky that's fine  the family you have makes you rich the  friends you choose makes them family  and with these things you will never  feel small  brace your body and be free  I just saw that one place in a sheep  that has no wool  parents Stream It on Disney Plus